you and your children are your best
friends it's kind of a it's a nice life
it was a family night for Angelina Jolie
on Thursday at the New York City
premiere of first they killed my father
the historical thriller she co-wrote and
directed while her sixteen-year-old son
Maddox worked on the film as an
executive producer
he's very studious he's very much more
than I am he's actually when we did our
notes in the production meetings his
were always better than mine he's got a
wicked sense of humor and he's very fun
to be with Angelina did interviews
alongside lalangue um her close friend
who wrote the book the film is based on
our friendship goes back so long and the
film is we were joking on the way here
we were laughing because we're both in
heels and trying to fix each other's
dresses and we met we were in a soaking
wet monsoon in our boots and we were a
little more comfortable crickets and
bugs I'm much more comfortable in better
than this
the film is means so much to to both of
us different reasons but many of the
same reasons once their whirlwind press
tour ends Angelina and LaJuan are
excited to take it easy at home hang out
have a glass of wine and then just relax
with the kids and watch a really good
scary movie we do we like to watch scary
movies
[Music]